now in real life you could have the best
of times and the worst of times but
under the Trump obsessed media it's all
bad all the time and you know things are
pretty good when the Trump's pissed off
storyline gets trotted out President
Trump
isolated growing more furious by the day
his mood dark and angry the president is
lashing out at the mullet probe the
president said to be in a foul mood
since the campaign and then among the
West Wing staff there is a near
universal sense of foreboding a universe
Universal sense of foreboding that's how
I feel after eating Taco Bell but Trump
he's mad so mad that maybe he'll stage a
coup in the sad event he does run and he
does lose which would be a happy event
it would be stunning what we would see
we wouldn't be a president I'm not
leaving I'm not leaving could call the
military I mean it is that we have to
look at this man and really would do
that I'm looking at that man fun fact
MSNBC made him in a lab with chicken
wire and Botox paste so now that the
apocalypse has been postponed until
after brunch we must make do with the
old chestnut trump's unstable and no
wonder would some networks stop talking
about how bad trump is what are you left
with them the empty talkers the
noisemakers in suits jaw clacking dolls
with broken hinges and tummy tucks they
cling to trump's mood like it's candy
colored clone a pen
even as the news looks pretty good for
America he just scored a bipartisan win
on prison reform even ban agrees the 99
times I don't agree with the president
I'm gonna give him he'll but on this one
I'll give him a salute and an applause
we've got to come together to help the
people at the bottom and while the
network's OD on Trump rage the
president's side to measure Monday to
create a new National Historic Park for
Martin Luther King jr. but wait how can
that be
how can Trump do this isn't he racist
the President of the United States is
racist well if he's a racist he's really
bad at it
Trump the world's worst racist you know
that's a great idea for a coffee mug
world's worst racist
world's best know also miss there was
the Medal of Freedom honors George
Herman Babe Ruth jr. George Herman Babe
Ruth jr. he was a junior I can imagine
what his father was I just love that
what's his father like all right then
you have Trump's arch hemorrhoid the
ambulance-chasing chuckle bucket Michael
a vanetti busted now that this isn't
funny it was busted on suspicion of
striking a woman allegedly of course the
CAD is innocent until proven guilty
that's what good people believe in even
if people like him don't he could be
innocent as innocent as Brett Kavanaugh
was when a vanetti was tormenting him I
just hope the media does a little
soul-searching after booking this clown
incessantly the media soul-searching
that's like looking for Bigfoot it's not
so long ago a vanetti was there darling
CNN and MSNBC were junkies to his
anti-trump crack but now he's toxic and
so the media that loved you pretends you
never dated it's like me and my
Backstreet Boys pajamas I pretty I
pretend I never owned them but for years
I wore them under my school uniform
which leads me to a new huge landmark
study on media trust The Hollywood
Reporter surveyed thousands of people on
who's the most trusted name in news now
I don't want to say the surprising
anchor who blew who blew away the
competition so we'll just throw to this
video
in 2018 a landmark poll surveyed
Americans to determine the most trusted
news media personalities the results are
in and one of the most trusted names in
news is none other than Greg Gutfeld
it's just another prestigious accolade
to the hosts of Cochran's his flagship
program the Greg Gutfeld show invested
some of the most established industry
insiders like Wolf Blitzer Stephanie
ruhle Katy tur John lemon Rachel Maddow
Brooke Baldwin Mika Brzezinski Chris
Cuomo Chris Matthews lawrence O'Donnell
and of course the absolute least
trustworthy name on the list Joe
Scarborough who came in at rank 49 out
of the 49 listed in the poll others were
barely able to come out ahead of Greg
Gutfeld those include Jake Tapper Dana
Perino Craig Melvin chris wallace andrea
mitchell harris faulkner brian williams
david muir Anderson Cooper and Lester
Holt but it's clear the real winner is
you America you get to watch one of the
most trustworthy charismatic and
handsome news media professionals six
days a week so join us in celebrating
televisions most prolific broadcaster
thank you Scarborough dead last maybe he
should have stuck to whatever he was
doing before TV when do we get the check
how does this work
I also beat Chris Cuomo and Don Lemon I
wonder how they took that don't be so
sensitive Chris sorry ma okay thank you
everything is not about you okay I'm
sorry
somebody looks like he better get after
it
but like I always say when life gives
you Don lemons go watch Greg Gutfeld I
also I also I also bested Rachel Maddow
how can that be Rachel I usually have so
many words I have the best words for
this I have no words
seriously this just happened Rachel
whoo-hoo-hoo all right but even I gotta
admit this is weird there's something
wrong what I'm more trusted than Wolf
Blitzer how can that be
he's boring and he has a beard which
makes him instantly trustworthy I mean
I'm flattered by this but I'm also
terrified me trusted by you I don't even
trust myself I won't even be alone with
me but here's the real problem the list
had mixed commentators with reporters
which is stupid
FNC has bolt but we clearly label what's
what other networks they aren't as clear
which is why so many people mistake
opinion for fact which leads to fake
news no wonder people think Trump is
crazy or insane
it's an opinion coming from their news
sources and that isn't healthy if we
only had something for that
[Music]
he would be a president I'm not leaving
I'm not leaving could call the military
Trump is gonna engineer a coup he's
gonna round up families and separate
children he's gonna imprison women and
turn them into baby-making factories
hold on there partner where'd you come
up with this well just watching TV and
talking to my friends hmm sounds like
you need new friends new friends tell me
more new friends is not a drug but a
group of people who present a different
set of opinions that more clearly
reflect reality in the talking heads on
TV Wow sounds great where do I start
first you'll want to go outside then
maybe go to a hardware store or a
grocery store or a local church no
playgrounds then initiate conversation
without mentioning politics do you have
neighbors yeah maybe talk to them about
the weather or sports or their pets I'd
love to talk about their pets do they
like you yes
oh no ever since I took down their Trump
signs that's okay
maybe apologize with a bottle of wine
sounds great I never thought of that
I'm gonna give it a try new friends is
the best way to keep you from going down
the paranoid angry rabbit hole that
turns people like Joe Scarborough and
Donny Deutsch into gibbering idiots act
now and we'll throw in this handy
Deutsch bag
it's a burlap sack that he plays over
your TV and Donnie is on TV so get new
friends today
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest publishers
grovel when he writes a new novel author
of up in the air and calmness at
harper's mag Walter Kirn he's a comedian
by night and a guy in his underwear by
day writer and comedian Joe DeVito
rookie quirky and a fan of beef jerky
natural review reporter cat tips his
stature is iconic his dinner plates
tectonic former WWE Superstar massive
sidekick and starting November 28 host
of unpeel 5 station Tyrus you've been
traveling the country give us your pulse
is it as dark is the mood dark is it is
it foreboding you mean is the mood of
the country the same as Trump's mood is
supposedly yes know the country is
partying like crazy you you get out
there people who haven't had jobs in 17
years or like you know can I buy you
lunch
but the Trump thing here's what's
happening they did all the President's
Men
you know Robert Mueller he's closing in
you know all the reporters now they've
moved on to the final days which was the
next Woodward Bernstein book about Nixon
praying you know two portraits late at
night so in their inability to imagine
anything other than a Nick Sounion
president there they're going even
further yeah any thoughts in a vanetti
no they say he looks like a certain male
Morgan
I've never thought that that's my only
thought you know I've never thought that
either until now Joe you haven't been
traveling the country you in fact you've
been shut-in since I can hold up yes
what are your thoughts on my on any
topic from the monologue you see fit I
think a vanity if you saw him playing an
evil lawyer in a movie Pacino would say
that's a little over the top
I like how Donny Deutsch says that
Donald Trump wouldn't respect the
results of an election gee who does that
sound like it's stripped by the way I
like your beard cat what do you make of
my award actually was an award it was my
my rating as being one of the most
trusted men in news you probably saw
that coming I'm just so happy to see you
happy thank you anything else no what
are your thoughts I'm just so glad that
I am NOT the president and that I don't
have everyone in the media analyzing my
mental state all day every day I was
just looking at that and imagining what
stories they'd say about me yes they'd
be like she wakes up every morning next
to an elf bobblehead doll you know like
she makes us listen to return of the
Mack on repeat during national security
briefings you know I own like 23 pairs
of penguin stocks why she keep tweeting
about lizards at 3:00 in the morning and
why is she always alone but thankfully
nobody knows any of those things no not
at all we do we know very little about
you virus
one thing you put you made an excellent
point that Stormies life was far better
before a vanetti and so this is a guy
who actually ruined a woman's life and
any woman's life you ruined a porn stars
like that that takes skill and talent
your characterization of avenatti was
not fair to pancreas as everywhere this
is a tough job yes see apparently you
were out on a mission I covered this a
few weeks ago writing a book or
something but I tired and she started
she was a director yes she was going
places
but she wasn't unveiling in those places
she was middle management right say
mm-hmm she had gotten money she signed a
way she was able to move on with her
life and not relive it and then he came
along dragged it all out he did TV shows
he got famous she got two bills one from
the President and one from the pancreas
yes and today she came out and said if
this is true yeah I'm out even if it's
not true stormy you don't take advice of
time get out yeah it's it's incredible
thing I get upset about this because our
president is so transparent presidents
pissed I like the President Obama don't
you dare but I'm pretty sure when he
lost the house yeah in the Senate it
wasn't cherries and smiles in the White
House that day yeah yeah I'm sure there
was a lot of who you looking at like
what do you want me to do I don't think
it was just well here we go guys I'll
gather around sing songs together I'm
sure some people's jobs were being
threatened yeah I'm sure he's like well
the pulse like I'm sure it was an
unhappy time yeah yeah yeah so for them
to say he's he's so mad they want him to
be mad I don't know why he doesn't play
it off like he just slam the door and
the last walk out in the front yard
why
like throw stuff around like live it up
you know yeah okay you're gonna move up
but I what's the irony here is that
Donald Trump treated stormy Daniels
better than Michael a vanetti did
because she got her hey he paid her and
it was a transaction that she was happy
with until he entered her life and said
no get more for me and that has
complicated matters for her to no end
but enough of that